(somber piano music)
- None of us ever know when
we're going to get sick
and I'm a nurse, I've
never had a cigarette.
I don't drink a sip of alcohol.
I got this disease.
What you learn is that you can't
have people around you who are negative
or what I have learned to
call the assassins of joy.
People that take your daily joy away.
It's really key and so important
to have people with
positive energy in your life
and to surround yourself with
as many positive people as you can.
There are so many
enchanting moments in life
and a lot of them have
to deal with interactions
between you and strangers.
The bagger at the Whole Foods steps up
and says, let me bag all your stuff,
go to the car with you and
put it in the car for you.
When you know you have a terminal disease,
it makes you enjoy everything.
So many of us are so
busy all day doing things
we miss enchanting moments,
we rarely capture them
and we rarely enjoy them.
We need to be grateful and thankful
for those moments and remember them
and let them help propel you
through the day with joy.
I think you need to choose well,
who you surround yourself with,
who you spend your time with,
what activities you engage in.
It'd be very easy when
you're not feeling well
to lay in bed for ten
hours and not do anything
but watch T.V.
I choose to paint, I choose
to do my art, play the piano.
When I go for five or six hours of chemo,
I don't go in my pajamas
and sit in the chair
like I'm a victim.
I bring my watercolors with
me, my quilting with me.
I bring some activity, I'm extremely busy
the whole entire time that
I'm getting my chemotherapy.
What you need to do is you
need to enjoy every moment.
You need to surround
yourself with good people.
You need to live your life with enjoyment,
energy, enthusiasm.
You need to look around
and help people around you.
Help people in your life.
I want to be remembered as somebody
who was enchanted by moments
all throughout the day
and someone who tried
to cause enchanting moments for others.
I want to be remembered as somebody
that brought joy into peoples
lives and who had integrity
and was a good person.
I want to be remembered as somebody
who passionately loves her
husband and her children
and her grandchildren and never acted
as the victim but always
has acted as the warrior
and was unafraid of anything.
(somber piano music)